hi this is kim from khan academy today
i'm learning about the sixth amendment
to the u.s constitution one of four
amendments in the bill of rights that
concerns the rights of the accused the
sixth amendment guarantees defendants in
criminal cases the right to a speedy and
public trial to learn more about the
sixth amendment i sought out the help of
two experts stefanos bibis is a united
states circuit judge for the u.s court
of appeals for the third circuit he's
also a leading scholar of criminal
procedure jeffrey fisher is professor of
law and co-director of the supreme court
litigation clinic at stanford law school
so judge bebis
in the case of the bill of rights
the framers were trying to prevent
particular abuses of the government so
what was the historical background that
led them to want to protect these rights
in particular
in england in the late 17th and early
18th century there was a series of
treason trials other political trials
and the king had done some things that
bypassed the usual mode of trial in
criminal cases the anglo-american system
is known as the common law it involves
live testimony in open court before a
jury of your peers
and the jury ultimately decides did you
do it were you blameworthy do you
deserve the punishment well the the the
crown had railroaded some of its
political opponents people like sir
walter raleigh people accused in the
popish plots
uh during the strife between catholics
and protestants and some of these
convictions were later understood to
have been
wrongful ones and so the colonists in
england and then in america insisted on
protecting against various
ways of diminishing or abridging the
trial that would be speedy that would be
public that would be before a jury that
would have an evenly matched prosecution
in defense and would have an opportunity
to to look the witness in the eye and
confront him the way it was always done
in england as opposed to on continental
europe there is a varied history
primarily in england
of
certain periods of time where
people were prosecuted in ways that the
founders deemed
fundamentally unfair probably the most
notorious example
was the star chamber that was a moniker
given to a king-run tribunal decades
before the founding where people were
picked up and arrested and then
sentenced to criminal punishment and
sometimes to death without ever having
an opportunity to challenge the charges
against them and sometimes not even
knowing what the charges were against
them
and so that kind of a travesty of
justice and abuse of power
was probably the foremost thing in the
framers minds this was partly for the
benefit of the defendant or the accused
it also was very importantly about
protecting the citizens right to control
criminal justice that it wasn't the king
who would do this and the king couldn't
just let his royal officers off so it's
very important to to look at the
declaration of independence a bunch of
the complaints in the declaration are
complaints that the king
is bypassing these usual modes that he's
protecting his soldiers by a mock trial
from punishment for murders which they
should commit on the inhabitants of the
states that he's depriving us in many
cases of the benefits of trial by jury
and that he has made the judges
subject to his
manipulation and pleasure because they
don't have
stable salaries uh so
the colonists were very suspicious of
the of the king's manipulation of
criminal justice so how does the sixth
amendment inform how the u.s legal
system works today well the first
important thing to understand is that
when the sixth amendment was drafted
just like all the other first ten
amendments
they applied primarily only to the
federal government not to state
governments
but in the
60s and 70s the supreme court
applied all of these rights one by one
to the states so now because the rights
apply to both the federal government and
to state governments
the sixth amendment applies every single
time uh somebody is charged with a crime
and so that starts uh with uh
knowing what you're being charged with
whether it's by what's known as a grand
jury indictment or some other method of
accusing somebody of committing a crime
and it continues on with
the right to an attorney to represent
the accused and goes all the way through
the decision-making process with how the
jury decides uh whether to convict or
not well this is fascinating but there
are a couple of things that i see in the
sixth amendment that seem like they
might be a little difficult to define
particularly the idea of a speedy trial
so what actually counts as speedy
the speedy trial component
is not well defined
the supreme court
has ultimately
said well
we're going to balance a bunch of
factors how long is the delay
what's the reason for the delay has the
defendant
shown any prejudice from the delay how
long did it take after the defendant
requested the speedy trial and
very rarely does the court actually
throw out a case based on that what
happens more often is that the defendant
makes a request and then judges really
try to push the case along to be faster
so the court has turned it into really
focusing on the defendant's interest in
something fast and that matters a lot
when a defendant doesn't make bail and
is being held in jail pending trial um
so those cases will go to trial in a
matter of of months
a case where someone is out on bail can
easily take a a year or two
before it ultimately proceeds to trial
what's speedy or what's reasonable in
1791
might not be speedy or reasonable uh in
2017.
so what the courts have said with
respect to speedy is uh there's not a
bright line rule say
one year uh five years whatever it might
be that somebody has to be brought to
trial after being charged
rather what the court does is it
considers
how diligently the prosecution has tried
to pursue the case in light of other
factors such as the complexity of the
case whether the defendant himself
wants the case to go to trial soon or
whether the defendant himself has agreed
to certain delays or said that
he doesn't mind them
and and whether there's prejudice that
has occurred which is a legal way of
saying um whether somebody's been uh
harmed or injured by the delay say for
example a key witness has now died or
fled the jurisdiction so it's it's
flexible words like speedy in essence
translate some measure of discretion and
flexibility to the courts
why is our legal process so much slower
than it was in the 18th century
okay so that that connects up to
the second set of rights we've we've
constructed around what makes something
a public trial and one of the main
things there is the jury right
uh
juries in the 18th century we didn't
have a jury selection process the first
12 people who didn't know
the plaintiff or the defendant or the
victim or whoever it was would be
empaneled and they would serve all day
and they'd hear all the cases that came
that day
and
you didn't have lawyers involved in most
of these cases usually it was the victim
against the defendant himself or herself
no lawyer speaking for either
side uh
that was the norm the defendant had a
right to hire a lawyer but usually
couldn't afford it and didn't
and there weren't rules of evidence
there weren't complicated
motions there weren't technical jury
instructions so the trials themselves
took as i said an hour two hours
pretrial proceedings did not involve
lots of legal motions because there were
no lawyers to run them the judges
themselves often didn't have legal
training there were no law schools in
america so when you have a system like
that it's not that cumbersome there's
very little incentive to bypass it and
you don't have professional lawyers who
are looking to get this case done with
and get on to the next case uh or who
have seen enough cases that they can
bargain back and forth and strike a
bargain for this case that's about where
the previous cases came out so you
didn't have an incentive for plea
bargaining it wasn't slow enough you
didn't have the experts who it would
take to run plea bargaining and you
didn't have the you know the lack of
investment in your own case that makes
plea bargaining possible or that the
technical rules um so these cases
actually all did go to juries and the
expectation was they all would go to
juries and the jury right wasn't it
wasn't just the right of a defendant
this happened in every case because the
public had a right to to do justice
itself as well as seeing justice done oh
i have so many questions about this so
for one thing do you think our current
system is an improvement on this older
system of juries and not so much
plea bargaining and
also
why is there so much plea bargaining
today
at the time of the founding
there were no deals to be made short of
a full trial that's a huge contrast with
today where over 90 of criminal cases in
this country are not resolved by trial
but rather by what's called a plea
bargain which is a defendant coming in
and saying
look i will plead guilty to a lesser
offense or to the same offence you're
charging but with a guarantee of lesser
punishment
as long as you don't
require me to go through a full trial
and so the idea is is that because the
system has grown so large
and there are so many cases uh that it's
a relief to the prosecution and the
court system not to have to have a trial
in every case and the benefit to the
defendant is that he gets a slightly
better deal or or is able to plead to a
lesser crime
over the course of the 19th century
prosecutors are really taking over most
of these cases it goes from a few
percent to the lion's share of cases and
then defense lawyers get hired more and
more to counteract that well once you
have prosecutors and defense lawyers on
both sides and the sixth amendment
guarantees you the right to hire a
defense lawyer that's how it's
understood in the 18th and 19th
centuries
the prosecutors and defense lawyers
develop rules of evidence and they
develop procedures and jury instructions
and they argue motions and so they get
more active and the judge gets more
passive or reactive so the judge isn't
pushing the case along as much and the
prosecutor and defenseless are slowing
it down now that seems like it makes it
fairer but once it gets to a certain
point of being slow
the prosecutors want to get rid of the
cases they have too many of them
the judges they have a bunch of civil
cases they need to get rid of and so the
prosecutors and the judges and the
defense lawyers all get together and
find ways to bargain the case away
rather than spending now it's days on
each case for trial
so from their point of view it makes
sense they have a faster system and
everyone goes home happy and the
prosecutor can pursue more cases and the
defendant gets
a lighter deal but the prosecution makes
sure there's some conviction and
sentence
but for the point of view of the public
the public doesn't see justice done and
the public doesn't trust these plea
bargains but at the end of the day what
the defense lawyer is mostly doing is
not making sure there's a speedy in
public trial but bargaining the 95
percent of cases away before there's a
trial uh what happens if the defendant
can't afford
a legal counsel
the the the history of the right to
council is actually one of the more
interesting components of the sixth
amendment because
many of the components have deep roots
in the history of england and so were
rights that englishmen
enjoyed
for many many years before they were
brought over to the colonies and became
part of our constitution of the united
states uh the right to counsel is a
little bit different in that respect uh
criminal defendants in england and other
countries around the time of
our founding often did not have a right
to counsel of any kind whether they
could pay for it or not
and so this was a bit of an innovation
on the fact of the on the part of the
framers recognizing that uh all the
other rights they were identifying to
defend yourself in court
might not amount to much if you didn't
have expert assistance or at least the
right to obtain expert assistance so
you've described a lot of changes to how
our legal system works over the years
what do you think would have surprised
the framers most about how our legal
system works today
i think they would have been
shocked that a system that was meant to
slow down and check governmental power
and protect overreaching and protect the
people's
role has been so subverted that the
people are involved in a few percent
of cases they designed a system that's
it's slower and less efficient by design
than the criminal justice system of
continental europe because they were
worried about
the king and the crown pushing pushing
around citizens and abusing their power
they wanted grand juries to authorize
every criminal charge well we've largely
gotten around that in most cases they
wanted petty juries to ensure that every
prosecutor's charge was justified and
that the legislature's criminal laws
weren't being applied too broadly and
again
prosecutors now have so many threats and
tools and sentences that they can make
almost everybody give up
their jury trial rights um but the
framers also weren't dealing with the
volume of cases we're talking about and
they weren't focused primarily on the
violent crimes the federal crimes they
were dealing with were
seditious libel criticizing the
government violations of the revenue
laws so
it's also fair to point out that
they did not expect that these rights
were mainly going to be limitations that
that benefited uh people in rape and
murder cases a lot of these protections
are mainly designed to to make sure that
the innocent people get get vindicated
against unjust charges and
they might be a little bit surprised
that almost all the litigation is is by
people who
may be factually guilty the next thing
that would have surprised the framers a
great deal i think uh is the role of the
jury uh today
the the jury trial right mentioned in
the sixth amendment is actually one of
the only
things mentioned twice in the
constitution the right to jury trial is
actually mentioned in the body of the
constitution itself
in article four
and then it's mentioned again in the
sixth amendment and the reason why is
because the jury were truly the people's
check on the court system and in
particular on
the prosecutorial power
so serving on a jury
to the framers
was an honor it was an act of
of of deep political participation and
meaning
in a way that we joke about jury service
today as being something of a nuisance
they viewed it as you know almost as
important as voting for the president on
election day by guaranteeing speedy
public trials by jury and due process of
law the sixth amendment ensures that
citizens not the government
control criminal justice but today as
professor fisher and judge bevis note
the framers might be surprised to learn
that due to the rise of pleague
bargaining only a small percentage of
cases go to trial by jury circumventing
this process to learn more about the
sixth amendment visit the national
constitution center's interactive
constitution and khan academy's
resources on u.s government and politics